now that it's been announced that I'm
going to be a dad I want to pick up some
tips on how to be a good day and what
better place to go to Than Ready
specifically kids are stupid
let's learn invisible suit we bought our
son an invisible suit he thinks the
neighbors can't see him
to be fair I feel like this is something
I would have done for sure I I remember
actually still just having such a
disconnect of what was possible
I remember arguing with my friend I'm
like if I lift myself up then why can't
I just fly they make sense why does no
one trying it actually no that never
happened I've been smart my entire life
thank you
[Applause]
oh
yeah I just kind of feel bad
no I don't dumb okay don't touch
anything what do you not understand okay
so this is a classic this is from Nathan
for you I highly recommend it his job
was to Market a toy that no one wanted
to use I think that was it when I show
this to you what do you think do you
want it nope nah why
dumb it's dumb yeah okay oh hold on a
second guys
I just got a call
hello
oh yes sir
really
oh my God yeah I'll let them know
sorry guys that was the president
calling and he just told me that owning
this toy is now the only proof you're
not a baby
well I mean I have one
so that's good are you guys babies or
nope nah well you don't have the toy so
you must be a baby yeah your baby
hahaha
oh okay so now you two aren't babies
but are you a baby
oh
you can see the thought process going
through now well you don't have the toy
hey it's a pretty cool toy okay when you
think about kids that don't have the toy
and actually I have one too you have it
as well of course otherwise you'd be a
baby and babies are banned from this
channel what do you think about kids
that don't have the toy inside
sad weird I love that part they
instantly judge other people it's like
some weird child psychology like oh yeah
they're weird you didn't have one two
seconds ago what the hell are you
talking about other children that don't
happen they're stupid they're sad look
how much fun they're having with it I
love how he said it's the president the
president told me but G fuel flavor
buddies is here these fruit guys are
running amok and the g fuel flavor
buddies buds I'll let you guys guess
what the flavors are this is Walter
melon this this is Lemmy this is cran
Drew this is raspberry these collectible
figures are inside a 40 serving energy
top of your choice and you will get a
random one each of them have different
Rarities and they also come in a chrome
version which is super rare two to three
percent I'll just show them stats there
you go so which one will you get
actually which one will I get I have not
unboxed this
[Music]
Eye Guy
oh I don't have that one what the
what are the odds this is Walter melon
what the what are you then oh he this is
Lemmy my bad let me my bad all right
cool I got them all
yeah yeah I got them all but you don't
have them all what are you a child this
is the only way to prove you're not a
baby by collecting them all
also comes with collector cup so yeah
pick your poison which flavor you want
I'm not gonna give you any hits on
whatever you should
and remember code PewDiePie at checkout
will give you 30 off which is a great
deal you're welcome prove once and for
all you're not a baby check out Link in
description all right let's keep
watching Bad Shakespeare for the first
time
[Music]
let me guess who's gonna cry
meridace
stupid child so dumb oh
this is like YouTube comments why did
she not
show that you have the thing otherwise I
don't know your baby
okay
when I ask a first grade class to write
letters to people in a nursing home
time's almost up all right it's kind of
savage all right I'm okay with that
Grandma you're about to hit that
hit the sack for the last time
foreign
[Music]
daddy we just want you to scare us
they've been scary what is this needed a
two minute break for my kids and they
tried breaking into my room what kind of
horror movie is this Daddy come out is
that what having kids is like
all right it's very cold now are you
sure you want to go inside in the water
yeah Henry you did a thing before you do
how do you think
you look at Mommy drive real hard
no do you understand it's very cold now
yeah look at Mommy
it would be very cold in your legs on
your feet it's too cold it may will hurt
you it's okay you know that before you
go to the water okay and when you get
cold on your feet Don't Cry For Me
do you understand because I already told
you it is super super super super super
super cool you got it yeah you got it
no you're sure right
you can check with your feet first
you still want to go to the war in the
water yes
yes you sure
yeah don't go that deep it's deep over
there
[Music]
that was probably the most
quintessential kids are stupid I've ever
seen it's like me when the waiter tells
me the plane is on excuse me I'll be the
judge of that I guess some things never
change
[Music]
there's a bear outside
survival instincts gone wrong it's
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
can they get one
oh my God I love their hyped about it
like yeah I beat a child my own child
let's go 88 tablet
you're gonna flip it
and you're gonna drop it
[Music]
it's just a scratch he dropped today in
what are you doing you need therapy you
need help this is why you need one of
these to play with to show that you're
not a baby and it won't break if you
flip it you know what maybe giving kids
iPads
isn't a good idea
[Music]
this is a hard one to get out
it's really wedged in there you're gonna
have to pull real deep idiot
fool if my child does this banished
banish to the island that's right I've
been talking about the island for years
where children will have to fight and
the strongest will survive it's not a
thing I looked it up but I will make it
a thing are you in good witch or a bad
witch
that was kind of cute
[Music]
while all the other kids forgot
Jesus hey whatever she's doing
oh that's so good these are so funny she
knows today's she just hates the dance
she got in the truck Maya continues to
turn down the ice cream I'm good you
sure yeah but both are interested to see
how the Music Machine Works wait is this
like a stranger danger test where the
guy comes out and be like what would you
do see it's this little box right up
here
I didn't think they would do that
as our ice cream man leaves hi guys bye
he's doing a good work
Maya tells her brother something just
isn't right Dallas we don't know him
stranger danger
ice cream
you make a compelling point
I like how he said ice cream but also
said you idiot at the same time
ice cream deep profound words perfect
example of day-to-day BS of parenting
can't wait for this all right
[Music]
it's not the same I get the child it's
not the same if she has already opened
it
[Music]
foreign
no okay
well at least you did it
I didn't expect her to actually like it
I did it
what happened here this is like a oh
what are you doing Colt awesome
yeah surprisingly I never did anything
like that at least that I'm aware of
Jesus Christ
[Music]
oh yeah I've seen this you're really
close to the ground just like let go
like a police
look how please there with themselves
laughs
I mean that could happen I actually
remember I got an RC car like that for
like my sixth birthday and I was so
freaking excited about writing that
because it was like I think it was
called like Big Bertha or something it
was huge before I went to school I was
like I should try it like just for a
minute it went literally half a meter
into the curb and then he broke the
suspension
and I never got to use it
oh man I think I traded it in for a Game
Boy caller so actually who's the real
winner after all
foreign
if you could go anywhere in the world
where would you go I will go that way
why a hot dog
let me rephrase that um actually
rephrase the first question so if you
could go anywhere at all in the world
where would you go
you just said it you idiot all right
he's the devil in France or that way
that way yeah you're not you're clearly
not listening all right Adam's just as
dumb clearly his seat belt as he settles
into the driver's seat one big problem
he's just seven years old dashboard
cameras capture Daniel wittenbach taking
his family's SUV for a morning Joyride
he's driving the wrong way into oncoming
traffic in Middletown Ohio cars swerve
to avoid young Daniels who's a decade
shy of getting his license I'm gonna
laugh because I know he'll be fine
playing music along the way but then the
inevitable happens he hits a median and
slows down another driver tries to help
wrapping a shirt around his hands trying
to smash in the window only then does
Daniel think he's going to get into
trouble
he didn't understand that people were
trying to help him and trying to stop
the vehicle another driver tries to body
block the SUV but it's a bad idea I
would not do that
okay you're okay Daniel wasn't hurt and
remains blissfully unaware of the danger
that he was in so where was he going his
only response is well I just wanted to
slushie from Speedway
I mean that's reasonable that's actually
Fair see this wouldn't happen in Europe
because we have the the clutch thingy
kids wouldn't be able to do that because
they're freaking stupid this is an
American problem as a monitor poisonous
why would you ask me that question no
reason doesn't wonder what
yes it's extremely poisonous and you're
going to die you have 60 seconds what
are you going to do I'll go over there
why would you ask if a market tip is
poisonous
fair enough oh I didn't read it so sorry
I just like scrolled through this is
their sleepover to-do list I'm concerned
about number two summoned
yeah
oh
God great
[Music]
what is happening
ah
I just can't imagine how she thought she
was gonna shoot
[Music]
ah
it wasn't that funny
oh
okay
well that one really got me man
okay reeling them
all right pick them up
[Laughter]
I mean it's not bad
count backwards yeah all right here we
go
ten nine
oh I mean she's not wrong
three oh
wow
oh my gosh
Ava where are you here
[Music]
[Applause]
does she not know she can start twerking
now like the kid in the start No One's
Gonna See it okay now watch the step go
slow over the step there you go good job
oh we spilled a little but that's okay
oh don't look at it
oh
did you panic it's okay it's okay your
sock got wet and you panicked it's all
right
[Music]
what was that quickly removal evidence
that I spilled
oh my God
[Music]
all right kids are very dumb we've
proved it here today except I enjoy it
will be extremely smart just like you
would gay extremely intelligent right
where's your toy we're still trying to
prove that you're not a baby you're
wearing diaper like baby all right let's
give your videos
[Music]